the sad fact of life is that even
superheroes die of course unlike the
rest of us they always come back to life
but while a lot of superheroes are
pretty straightforward deaths Tony
Stark's trips to the hereafter are
downright weird 1987's armor was told
the story of Tony Stark finding out that
villains were using his designs to power
their own armored costumes and then
doing everything he could to take that
technology back it also featured the
first time the iron man died sort of the
thing is the armored Avenger didn't go
down swinging while battling to save the
world he mainly died because it was the
best PR move while it might seem like a
good idea to take his inventions back
from the bad guys Tony's quest also
meant taking on shield and beating up
stingray a third-string Avenger even
worse Tony then took a trip to Russia
where he caused an international
incident and accidentally killed an old
rival the titanium man with a growing
list of international crime stacking up
Tony realized that there was only one
thing left to do in order to keep both
his personal reputation and his
companies from being completely
destroyed he made a full confession and
explained he was doing it for the
greater good you want my property you
can't have it but I did you a big favor
I have successfully privatized world
peace now just kidding instead he
created a false identity named R and L
Pierce claimed that PS being the one
wearing the armor all this time then
faked Randall's death the next month
there was a brand new Y a man in
brand-new armor who just happened to
sound like act like and know all the
same things as a daily departed mr.
Pierce faking your death is like eating
a potato chip you can't just stop at one
this time it started when Tony was shot
by an ex-girlfriend in 1989 which left
him unable to walk without his armor
since using technologies to deal with
injuries that worked so well before Tony
decided to implant some microchips in
his back and accidentally created other
physical problems I started to kill him
anyhow oops
after Tony spent some time heroically
threatening to murder Justin Hammer
unless he sold him his company for $1
stark contacted his lawyer made his
final arrangements and apparently died
in reality he went into cryogenic stasis
until another scientist could sorts out
to spinal software problems all while
letting even close friends like Rhodey
think he was dead this one gets
complicated back in 1995 Marvel
published The Crossing a store
Lynott revealed that Tony Stark had
secretly been murdering people behind
the scenes for years including killing a
fellow Avenger called yellowjacket on
the doorstep of avengers mansion it
wasn't entirely his fault though it
turns out that Tony had been manipulated
by a time-traveling super villain named
immortus when it was all revealed Tony
completely lost there and wound up
fighting the Avengers and a younger
version of himself before finally
sacrificing his life to stop the plot
had been an unwilling part of with that
Tony Stark was dead going out in one of
the most ignoble deaths a superhero has
ever experienced the good news though is
that all this happened when and because
very few people were actually reading
Iron Man comics so nobody really cared
some about that younger version when
Tony Stark was revealed to have gone bad
like a cartoon of year-old milk
The Avengers had to take action decided
that what they really needed to do was
go to another dimension and get a
teenage version of Tony and then make
him fight his own murderous adult self
really guys you couldn't have sent Thor
on the hope to take care of him instead
Oh what it might surprise you to find
out that this plan did not work out very
well fortunately after the old Tony died
the new version survived for about 10
months then came onslaught a crossover
in which a mingling of minds between
Professor X and Magneto produced an
all-powerful third entity onslaught
initially appeared as a hulking armored
figure that looked like someone had
tried to make magneto entirely out of
knives but when the heroes teamed up to
stop him they discovered that this
wasn't even his final form instead he
evolved into a being of pure intangible
psychic energy and unless they could
contain onslaught and some kind of
physical body that never be able to
destroy him that captures our unsought
fed on mutant energy so if any of the
x-men tried to finish what their bus
started onslaught would only get
stronger thanks to that little catch the
Avengers on Fantastic Four jumped into
onslaughts brain tornado and broke him
into manageable bite-sized chunks that
all the mutants could zap into dust with
that's a team Tony had Eroica Lee
sacrificed himself to save the world
only to be reborn as an adult Tony on an
imaginary earth created by Reed Richards
son and then reborn once again back on
regular Marvel earth a year later in
short 1996 was a hell of a year for Iron
Man fans once Tony have returned to
Earth and adulthood he created a new
suit that he nicknamed the safe armor
true to its name it was a little boy
keya and more defensive than some of the
other suits and even had an advanced
artificial intelligence that was
designed to keep its occupant from being
harmed needless to say that advanced AI
did what every advanced AI in comics
does it became sentient and immediately
went evil something that no one could
have predicted when Tony used pieces of
Ultron in order to create it you know
Ultron a genocide or robot that once
massacred an entire country yeah and
nobody could have possibly seen this
coming
irin terribly naive the story played out
with the armor acting like an obsessive
ex-lover a bit of subtext that was only
made less subtle once the armor went
full fifty shades and tied Tony up all
shouting things like get inside me Tony
the whole time however it was creating
an advanced nervous system that would
allow it to feel the full range of human
emotion and what had apparently save
things like not killing people for last
they showed up just in time when Tony
had a heart attack while they were
fighting the armor tore its own hearts
out and used it to save his life after
that Tony buried the armor complete with
a grave marker that read he allies Iron
Man Avenger check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superheroes
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]